are you in trouble
I need my birth certificate why
imma be a Marine
the inspection is a story about a
homeless black gay young man who joins
the Marines in search of acceptance from
his mother this is all I have left of
the dream I held for you in many ways
the inspection is a story of survival
and determination the will to endure
with the faith that you can overcome are
you now or have you ever been a
homosexual no sir
I will break you I love working with
artists who there's that active question
of what more can I find Gabrielle Union
she brought her all they kicked you out
and I've been crafting Inez it's not who
I am I just trust an Elegance as a
director and believe in a way that I had
never really believed in myself this
performance is transformative
inspirational but I believe Gabrielle
Union is given the performance of her
career really was a special
collaboration working with her finding
that groove of how we exist as French
knees on camera the real hope lies in
human connection you don't always get
another tomorrow to get it right this
boy is gayer than two left shoes you all
had no business let him in here
oh he is to us is our marine Marines
I could have left you at any doorstep
never giving up on us
[Music]